first off these are a little dried
shrimp you can buy them anywhere they
smell almost sort of the seabed into the
pests and water for this salad inspired
by my travels across Thailand I'm
starting by making a wonderfully spicy
paste a little salt in there in just
break them up this place is like a
staple ingredient in Thailand that's
what we're looking for
almost it's like a powder right next
just one clove of garlic slice up the
garlic and get that into the pestle
mortar Birds Eye chili incredibly hot
powerful but Wow
it does give an amazing kick to the
paste in to the mix now a couple
tablespoons of brown castor sugar that
softens the blow with a chili and then
just to get that nice sour taste a
little bit of hot water into this
tamarind paste it's really tart but
sweet pace one tablespoon in fish sauce
now it's got that almost sort of pickly
smell slightly salty but the flavor is
intense two tablespoons and bring that
together and give it a really good mix
some lime juice in half another touch of
full tartness
the pace is nice and thick and fragrant
but it's got the heat the sounds the
tartness incredible green papaya stand
it up give it a little peel you can find
green papaya in local Asian shops and
bigger supermarkets and as it doesn't
work like more delicate veg it's perfect
for robust salads like this migrate it
no that's what I want the thin slithers
next a nice rich sweet banana shalat
nice some cara cara gives it another
texture
now little that mixing
finish that off with Thai basil and
fresh coriander Thai basil is a much
more fragrant basil it's stronger anise
slightly thicker as well like papaya and
tamarind paste you can get Thai basil in
good supermarkets and independent Asian
stores but nor basil works well too next
prepare the crunchy topping pan on and
toast some peanuts chop the nuts I think
it's a really nice crunch then they go
rolling around the pan gas off and just
tip them out now for the exciting part
we're gonna dress the salad nice spoon
of dressing in to the papaya mix that in
and finally a nice general sprinkling
roasted nuts and that is one delicious
very fragrant very robust green papaya
salad so easy to make and guaranteed not
to go limp a perfect party salad and
with such incredible colors textures and
bold exciting flavors it's sure to grab
your guests attention don't hold back
with the herbs they'll really help make
the filling vibrant fresh and aromatic
finally touch alive just next add capers
fresh dill and slices of lemon